before they hijacked those airplanes on
9 11 20 years ago tomorrow osama bin
laden's terrorists made multiple visits
to las vegas and two decades later we
still don't know for sure why they were
here george knapp the i-team has our
story
it occurred to you that we could be a
target
well we who knew i mean you know we
there were still planes flying when we
were having this decision they had made
the grounding but they hadn't all landed
yet former sheriff jerry keller says
there had been almost no discussion of
las vegas as a possible target for
attack by the likes of al qaeda prior to
the events of 9 11. but in the hectic
hours after the hijackings keller and
the other agency heads who gathered at
fbi headquarters started thinking the
unthinkable at that time i mean
terrorism
was thought to be a foreign state issue
within days local anxieties increased as
the fbi shared classified information
with keller including details still not
widely known these guys were here there
were a couple of other things there was
a a guy that
they tracked in arizona you know that
was planning to come across the dam
so you know there was nothing never
happened from that but that was early
information ringleader muhammad ara and
at least four of the other 19 hijackers
made six visits to las vegas between
late may and mid-august atta who piloted
the first plane into the world trade
center flew to las vegas on june 28
rented a car then spent 90 minutes
online in an internet cafe across from
unlv he checked into the econo lodge on
las vegas boulevard within shouting
distance of the fbi office put a do not
disturb sign on his door and stayed two
nights in a room that faced the
stratosphere tower when he returned his
rental car on july 1st it had 110 miles
on it don't know where don't know where
it i mean it does raise the central
scariest question that there might be
somebody here that helped them met with
them absolutely without a doubt
but chances are
um
i'm guessing that whoever was here
also came here from somewhere else and
they met up we just didn't ever figure
out who they were at the time future
sheriff bill young was in charge of
special ops teams for metro his
detectives and fbi agents poured through
mountains of hotel records rental car
receipts and surveillance videos to
document the terrorist movements
tipsters say at least one terrorist
received lap dances at olympic garden
others sipped coffee across from unlv
partied and gambled at casinos many
leads from the public could not be
confirmed the biggest questions remain
unanswered were they
pre-operational planning for something
here in las vegas gathering intel
were they here to plan operations
elsewhere
were they here to have their last hurrah
before they go get their
72 versions or virgins or whatever they
get and you know i'm i'm not sure
and i don't think anybody can
definitively say the hijackers weren't
the only visitors of note that summer on
9 11 itself more than a hundred members
of the saudi royal family and their
friends the bin ladens were staying in
las vegas mostly at caesar's palace and
the four seasons osama bin laden's
sister was well known at the bellagio
the saudis were grounded along with
everyone else but after being
interviewed by the fbi days later were
cleared to leave aboard three special
charter flights they were here they were
they're always here
they've been here since some of them are
gamblers
high rollers good customers
in the 20 years since 9 11 police in las
vegas and elsewhere have undergone vast
changes in how to prepare for and
respond to possible terrorist attacks
metro has greatly enhanced its own
intelligence capabilities what's also
changed is the nature of the threat
homegrown domestic terrorists are as
much or more of a threat as the foreign
variety says sheriff joe lombardo the
paradigm has changed a lot george over
the years since 9 11 you know the crux
was foreign terrorism
and then now the proliferation of
like-minded groups via the internet and
other social media spaces uh come
together and domestic terrorism has
become readily prevalent in the law
enforcement and terrorism space george
knapp 8 news now
and you can watch more of our full
interview with sheriff lombardo about
the aftermath of 9 11 on our website at
8newsnow.com brian